people love
book recommendations let me ask what
three books oh you can't just like you
can't just give me three
i mean like really three what uh seven
and a half
books you can recommend so you're also
the author of seven and a half lessons
about the brain
your uh author of uh how emotions are
made
okay so definitely those are the top two
recommendations of all the two greatest
books of all time
other than that are there books that uh
technical fiction philosophical
that you've enjoyed or you might
recommend to others yes
actually you know every phd student when
they
um when they graduate with their phd i
give them a set
of like a little library like a set of
books you know some of which they've
already read some of which i want them
to read or
but i think non-fiction books
i would read the things i would
recommend are
the triple helix by uh
richard luanton it's a little book
published
in 2000 which is um i think a really
good introduction to
complexity and um
population thinking as opposed to
essentialism so this idea essentialism
is this idea that you know
there's an essence to each person
whether it's a soul or your genes or
what have you as opposed to this idea
that
you we have the kind of nature that
requires the nurture
we are we are you are the product of a
complex dance
between um an environment
between a set of genes and an
environment um
that turned those genes on and off to
produce your brain and your body
and really who you are at any given
moment
title for that triple helix so playing
on the double helix where it's
just the biology is bigger than the
biology exactly
um it's a wonderful book i've read it
probably six or seven times throughout
the year he has another book too
which is it's more i think scientists
would find it
i don't know i loved it it's called
biology as ideology
and it really is all about i wouldn't
call it one of the best books of all
time but
i i love the book because it really does
point out
you know that science science as it's
currently practiced i mean the book was
written in 1991 but it actually i think
still holds
that scientist science is currently
practice has a set of ontological
commitments which are somewhat
problematic
so the assumptions are limiting yeah in
ways that you it's you know it's like
you're a fish in water and you don't
like okay
so yeah so here's the foster walls yeah
stuff but you know but here's the
here's a really cool thing i just
learned recently
is it okay just to to go off on this
tangent for a minute yeah yeah
that's called tangency great okay um i
was just gonna say that
i just learned recently that we don't
have water receptors
on our skin so how do you know when
you're sweating how do you know when
when a raindrop when you know when it's
going to rain and you know like a
raindrop hits your skin and you can feel
that little
drop of wetness how is it that you feel
that drop of wetness when we don't have
water receptors in our skin and i was
when i my mind's blown already
yeah that was my reaction too right i
was like
of course we don't because we evolved in
the water yeah like why would we need
you know it just it was just this like
you know you have these moments where
you're like oh
of course there's like a yeah so you'll
never see rain
the same way again so the answer is it's
a it's a
it's a combination of um temperature
and touch but it's a complex
sense that's only computed in your brain
there's no receptor for it
anyways yeah that's why like snow
versus cold rain versus warm rain all
feel different because you're
you're trying to infer stuff from the
temperature and the size of the droplets
it's fascinating
yeah your brain is a prediction machine
it's using lots and lots of information
combining it you know anyway so but um
so biology is ideology
is i wouldn't say it's one of the
greatest books of all time but it is a
it is a really useful book there's a
book by
um if you're interested in psychology or
the mind at
all there's a wonderful book a little
it's a
fairly fairly small book called naming
the mind
by kurt danzinger who's a historian of
psychology
everybody in my lab reads both of these
books
so what's the book it's about the origin
of the where do
where did we get the theory of mind that
we have
that uh the human mind is populated by
thoughts and feelings and
um perceptions and where did those
categories come from because
they don't exist in all cultures
also this isn't that's a cultural
construct
the idea that you have thoughts and
feelings and they're very distinct is
definitely a cultural construct
it's another mind-blowing thing just
like the rain
um so kurt danzinger is a the
opening chapter in that book
is absolutely mind-blowing i
love it i love it i just think it's
fantastic
um and i would say that
there are many many popular science
books that i could recommend
that i think are extremely well written
in their own way you know
before i maybe i said this to you but
before i undertook
writing how emotions are made um i read
i don't know somewhere on the order of
50 or 60
popular science books to try to figure
out how
to write a popular science book because
while there are many
books about writing stephen king has a
great book about writing
on writing and um you know where he
gives tips
um interlaced with his own personal
history
um that was where i learned you write
for a specific person
you have a specific person in mind and
that's for me that person is my is down
that's fascinating i mean that's a whole
nother conversation to have like
which popular science books like what
you learned from that
uh search because there's uh
i have some for me some popular science
books so like i just roll my eyes like
this is too
um it's the same with ted talks like
some of them go
too much into the flowery and don't
i don't i would say don't give enough
respect to the intelligence of the
reader
uh and but that's this is my own bias
very specifically i i
completely agree with you and in fact i
have a colleague his name is
um van yang who you know he um
produced um a cinematic lecture
of how emotions are made that we wrote
together with
joseph friedman no relation yes
um well we're all related well i mean
you and i are probably you know
have some yeah yeah um but remember
it's the memories are in there somewhere
yeah it's from many many many
generations ago
um well half my family is russian so
from
the good half the good half right
um but you know he
one of his goal actually is to produce
um
[Music]
you know videos and lectures that are
beautiful and educational and that don't
um don't dumb the material down
um and he's really remarkable at it
actually i mean just uh but again you
know that's good that that requires a
bit of a paradigm shift we could have a
whole conversation
about the split between entertainment
and education in this country and why it
is the way it is but
that's a that's another conversation
should be continued but i would say
the if i were to pick one book that i
think is
a really good example of good science
writing it would be the beak of the
finch
which one uh it won a a pulitzer prize
a number of years ago and i'm not
i'm think i'm not remembering the
author's name i'm blanking
um but the i'm guessing is it uh
is it focusing on birds and the
evolution of birds
actually there's also the evolution of
beauty yes
yeah yeah which is also a great book but
the
no the beak of the finch is um it's a
it it has two story lines that are
interwoven one is
about darwin and darwin's
um explorations in the galapagos island
and then modern-day researchers from
princeton who have a research program
in the galapagos looking at darwin's
finches
and um it's just
a really first of all there's top-notch
science in there
and really science like you know
evolutionary biology that a lot of
people don't know
and it's told really really well it
sounds like they're all so
there's a narrative in there there's
it's like storytelling too
yeah i think all good popular science
books are storytelling for just you know
but storytelling grounded constrained by
you know the evidence and then i just
want to say that there are
for fiction i'm a really big fan of love
stories just to return us to the um
the topic that we began with and so my
some of my favorite love stories are
major pettigrew's last stand by helen
simonson
it's a it's a love story about people
who you wouldn't expect to fall in love
and all the people around them
who have to overcome their prejudices
and
and um i love this book
what do you like what makes a good love
story
there isn't one thing you know there are
many different things that make a good
love story but
i think in this case um you can
feel you you
can feel the journey you can feel the
journey
that these characters are on and all the
people around them
are on this journey too basically to
come to grips with this
really unexpected love really profound
love that develops between these two
characters who are very unlikely to have
fallen in love but they do
and it's just it's very gentle
another book like that is um the
um the storied life of aj fearkey
which is also a love story but in this
case it's a love story
between um a little girl and her adopted
dad
and the dad is this like real
curmudgeony
you know um guy
uh but of course there's a story there
and um it's just a beautiful
love story and but it also it's like
everybody in this community falls in
love
with him because he falls in love with
her
and he you know she just gets left at
his store
his book story has this failing
bookstore and
he discovers that
you know he feels like inexplicably this
need to take care of this little baby
and um this whole life emerges out of
that one decision which is
really beautiful actually um
it's very poignant do you think the
greatest stories
have a happy ending or
a heartbreak at the end that's such a
russian question it's like
it's like russian tragedies you know so
i would say the answer to that for me
there has to be
heartbreak yeah i really don't like
heartbreak
i don't like heartbreak i want there to
be a happy ending
or at least a hopeful
ending but the but you know like dr
chivago like or the english patient
oh my goodness like why
oh it's just yeah no um
well i don't think there's a better way
to end it on a happy note
like this uh lisa like i said i'm a huge
fan of yours thank you for
wasting yet more time with me talking
again
people should definitely get your book
and uh maybe
one day i can't wait to talk to your
husband as well well right back at you
[Laughter]
lexi
you